this is Startalk this is Startalk and
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist I serve as
director of New York City's Hayden
Planetarium right here in New York City
and today's edition is the fan-favorite
cosmic queries I've got with me
Godfrey Don Chima hey Godfrey it's
happened welcome back thank you for
having me banshee my Nigerian and team
ah yes it's Maya Tokyo its own I had
total don't you all
there's plenty can I tell you something
was that the Japanese pronunciations are
the same as African pronunciations so
today's topic yes I is what is it it's
it's space-time space-time very nice I
like space-time and here we go so my
best friends live in the fabric of
space-time there it is all right listen
I haven't seen any of these and it
called from our social media okay here
we go
mm-hmm okay Kyle yokum's spelled with C
but it's still pronounced Kyle from
Tennessee when I've heard that name
before is he one of our patreon PE is
your patreon patron oh yes I so he
bought his way to the top of this list
oh yeah he's not he's not planned I mean
you got a lot of space time I put money
in that huh I got a lot of money in that
space no it's better if you supports the
show their perks you get you do right on
up the ladder and this is just one of
them but there's others yeah great I
think he deserves it he's always at the
top Yocum I love that last name Yocum
okay ready yeah remind me some Yocum if
Isaac Newton were alive again today
which of our more read not be able to
hold my pee Yeah right it would be kind
of nice yeah we gripping him like a
fanboy and I would totally yeah yeah
would you like touch his wig did they
well yeah I would touch his wig probably
no no I wouldn't touch why why you get
me to say that I would go but you make
him out to be no [ __ ] baby no no nothing
come on some thug that knows about
please like no I'm not touching his wig
okay okay
sir Angela Davis came forward into the
present kitchen can I touch your fro no
that's true she was slap you silly she
would slap us oh okay
even today right if Isaac Newton were
alive again today which of our more
recent understandings about the universe
do you think he might find most exciting
if you were to get to work with him on a
particular project of your choice what
would that be and why he was so
brilliant I would just I would present
all the world's problems to him no
matter whether or not they were in
physics and just to get his brilliant
mind to apply to it really I just I've
read his writings and you can't the hair
stands up on the back I don't have hair
there but if I had hair it would stand
up on the back of my neck because he was
so plugged in to the operations of
nature he had an understanding
he had a sensitivity to what we knew and
did not know and where the frontier was
to ask questions there's a whole section
of one of his books one of his books
optics wrote in seventh written in 1704
understood uh yeah they talk differently
out there I don't know I'm just so you
learn how to read you know yeah so the
language was a little more classical
yeah for English you know at the time
yeah not quite
Shakespeare right that was a hundred
years earlier but it's transitioning
even the writing with independence to be
able Divya penmanship is different and
even the printed words are different
right some words are capitalized and
others are not I do that in my Twitter
stream by the way I capitalize certain
nouns okay I want to bring attention to
like the V's would be like use although
that's different so that would add about
that would be the use would be like
these he's like you admit at CES or
whatever in Roman times with the yeah
yeah annoying what are you was fully
developed as a letter it took somebody
to go put a butt on it the evolution of
language yeah so I would I would learn
how to communicate with him that
wouldn't be too hard because he's still
speaking English okay and so we speaking
recognizable English so so I would just
show them all the problems we have a
famine issue we got this issue but the
problem is and I've gone through this
mental exercise many times
you sit him down yeah okay and he hears
some car noises outside said what's that
I said it's a car and he says what's a
car oh it's a horse-drawn carriage
without the horse so then he says well
what draws it and I said Oh an engine
and so what's an engine well it uses
fuel
well what's fuel well it's gasoline well
what's gasoline
well it's fossilized ancient dead
extinct
what's extinct oh you did none of these
ideas existed in his day Wow but he'd be
annoying what I liked that I ate your
old kid yeah was asking questions I
would be like she shut up Isaac Jesus
law of inertia I push him huh every most
everybody in motion right every man I
feel is in mosted I I'd say we use
chemical energy okay he says what is
chemical energy what is energy because
energy was not a fully developed idea in
his day that would take another hundred
years right so so conversation would be
really but he's a quick study so I think
okay human afternoon he just kept asking
you questions
oh no I mean it would be like what what
is that what what is that
and they'd both walking God he will
emerge like the most brilliant person
got it once he got it he said Trump what
is trauma yeah our top scientists
they'll figure it out with many
laboratories in the world so I think he
would be very intrigued by Einstein's
relativity general theory because those
were extensions of his theories of his
laws of motion and gravity Einstein's
relativity are extensions so I said
special theory of relativity is the
continuation of Newton's laws of motion
and Einstein's general theory of
relativity is the continuation of
Newton's laws of gravity so he would he
would be intrigued how his ideas failed
and then Isaac and and my goodness yeah
you got it right these ideas failed and
and
Einstein's picked up to take two regimes
that he never even dreamt up do you
think that Isaac Newton would be a hater
who would be like this yo oh man is they
say yo you know the stuff you were
talking about well this guy took it to
the next level nothing could be like
math get that dude you know and I I
don't you know they hate a little bit
said that he wouldn't say it that way
I'm sorry had to be something at this
dude that do even like dot slow like
this I can't believe he actually took my
theories that roughly on him took my
publishing nothing ruffian yeah what up
ruffian he was in dispute with with
Leibnitz who's a German philosopher
right mathematician who they could
there's a contention between the two who
invented calculus oh by the way Newton
is not even best known for having
invented calculus
that's how brilliant he was that's how
brilliant just like react yes calculus
was basically on a dare my friend said
why do the planets orbit the Sun any in
this shape and not this ellipse and not
some other shape yes I don't know I'll
get back to you I'll get back here get
back it comes back in a month later
here's why how did you figure it out I
had to invent integral and differential
calculus I answer your question I
couldn't pass Isaac um I guess I
invented something that you couldn't
learn I armed for him to see that to see
that if he was Z um Einstein's whatever
you call it I mean no but he would feel
like a failure though he wouldn't know
because he was the foundation of it all
there was no Industrial Revolution
without the intellectual muscle of Isaac
Newton so no no the man was never any so
you said you talked about that German
philosopher siren cutting you off and
they they they dispute each I say
disputed and it's clear they came up
with it independently of one another
around the same time that's just like
Einstein around the time Bohr's and all
those guys Madame cute they were all
hanging out everybody's to get each
other right in fact if Einsteins Berg
Heisenberg Eichenberg sigh yeah
so Werner von Heisenberg oh is that all
this is what I have one more time
on in there but what a vital thing I can
just put in a vault I think it's just -
Brad yeah suddenly you need it apart
what happens at the beginning holds
water and bomb whatever any of those
mean you know what my name my name is in
German is Gottfried Godfrey oh yeah okay
I like God for it it means gods get the
peace got feet oh really
what yeah okay this is know that digital
the Neil deGrasse Tyson at nine no night
night I but they had I thought they
because I know when I read I actually
went read Walter Isaacson's biography on
China huh
and so one of many great biographies
written everything of Steve Jobs yeah
amazing no I I saw that picture they all
took it was Boers um Heisenberg all all
those guy hitters Adam Curie pr2 all of
I think they all long outweigh Johanna
and they discovered the modern physics
yeah birth of quantum mechanics
unbelievers of relativity I believe yeah
they're all haters a little bit I don't
know I hate it on you know it is it's
friendly competition that's true that's
true that's just all it okay
next all right what that was awesome
right to comply warring football teams
don't really hate one another really
know I on the field maybe afterwards did
happen to be issue or yeah they're
having a beer we talked about I don't
know cowboy guys okay here we go our
next one Steve Latham Facebook Steve
Staffordshire England if the shape of
the universe is hyperbolic or hyperbolic
hyperbolic thank you
hyperbolic paraboloid then why doesn't
the universe expand evenly
thanks he says as far as we know the
universe is expanding evenly
uniformly is the right word so wherever
you are you will measure the same
expansion rate of the universe okay no
matter what and so that would mean it's
expanding uniformly and so yeah I don't
I don't know why he thinks there's a
problem there it's a sheep well the
two-dimensional version is a sheet we
all pull on the edge of the sea we all
start pulling right okay and dots on the
sheet will all start
moving away from one another all at a
uniform rate and so that's how we
measure this we see this so ya know when
it's not a problem you think that it was
just a bad question
there are no bad question Arnold okay
alright but is this a serious question
no no people do do they do serious
homework for volatile boyd wow it's nice
that sounds like a problem likely your
bladder yeah no no no it's appointment
fix that right up
hyperbolic paraboloid do you have
hyperbolic paraboloids we got a new
sound so you it sounded like an auditory
auditory no more hyperbolic rambling
okay here we go next one is this fill
SAS a our fast it might be fill SAS I
don't mean to pronounce mispronounces
last name fill sounds from Georgia USA
alright if we decided to launch a manned
exploration spacecraft how long would it
take for it to explore the entire galaxy
and how could we prep prep it for such
an undertaking yeah it depends on how
fast you're going
let's go to the speed of light okay okay
now if they managed to go the speed of
light they won't age but we will so at
the speed of light it would take 100,000
years to cross the galaxy so we're all
dead and none of us will remember that
we ever launched you anywhere so that's
a Tau beat of light speed of light to
suffice speed of light yeah okay so now
let me reshape the question a little bit
because there's an interesting there's a
fascinating Avenue that comes out of
this it turns out that if you created a
robot that could use resources on the
planet and lands on to replicate itself
uh-huh so to make two robots and then
send one robot off to another planet
right okay let's say sweet robots send
off to one stays yeah so then they then
make two robots okay and if you keep
this up you can populate the galaxy over
and at what we call an evolution
a lifetime so over much less than the
age of a star so over hundreds of
thousands millions of years you can
significantly populate the galaxy right
and this led to what was at the time
known as the Fermi paradox because any
alien who could do that
would have done that by now and easily
have populated the entire galaxy in the
time the universe has been around right
so he asked where are they now
right I'll come they're not among us so
I have two responses one of them is
maybe we are they oh like that or the
one I just say all the time because it's
like it's a cheap and easy crackit our
species so maybe they did come and take
a look and conclude there's no sign of
intelligent life on earth that's so mean
no that's for these dummies we're out I
know we're out we're out yeah go to
China Mao we out two minutes left on
this segment okay both okay
how many physicists does it take to
change a lightbulb
that's a quantity Hornet Facebook how
many physicists how many physicists does
it take to change a light bulb yes
since it's physicists arm who invented
the LED right
going forward the physicist will never
have to change the light bulb it will
burn longer than their lifespan boom
next forget little smart little a
question blow so just a bit over so two
Nobel Prizes ago or one Nobel Prize ago
the Nobel Prize in Physics was to a team
of physicists who invented the blue
light-emitting diode we had had a green
we had the red okay okay we never didn't
have a blue now that we have the blue we
have RGB you can make any color at all
using LEDs and the fact blue open the
tire lighting market that's why you go
you can't even get a light bulb that you
need to change yeah oh yeah in a
hardware store right am i right
you're right you're right oh that's it
so again how many physicists does it
take they were clever enough to remove
the meaning of the question itself oh
man I love that this cosmic way of
destroying that dude is awesome hunter
whatever your name is if you're slick
with your little joke know your lesson
we are we going 21 okay okay okay okay
go I'll get the space/time have limit or
is it infinite if we're on a spaceship
going faster than light would we stop
eventually because we reach the edge and
there is no more space nor time this is
guy is a psycho EXO Instagram from
France
Cyril tor friends whoa well there's no
time to answer the second okay you'll
have to wait until the next segment of
cosmic queries on Startalk we'll see in
a moment
we're back on Startalk I got Godfrey
here is a free man Jimo what rose it was
last night
I'm sorry that's why I'm Godfrey Godfrey
just Godfrey and she mother said she
Vincenzo but I know I'm Ben Gunn
remember 900 billion galaxies is it man
chimo excellent now that good with names
but I'm good with mathematical
calculation on Timothy I got Oh funny I
got a med team on munching all dead men
you African right same thing said what
you're they're ready so we we let lose a
cliffhanger there cliffhanger yeah I
want to know was there an edge to the
universe
yeah just kept traveling so so here's
the thing we do not know how big the
actual universe is there is the size of
the universe we see and like from the
edge of that universe has been traveling
for 13.8 billion years to reach us
now of course over that time the
universe has expanded the actual
universe is bigger than that today
it's bigger than that but you have to
ask beyond that horizon is there more
universe to be found we can only assume
yes but we don't know for sure but it's
that isn't that just and it could be
infinite and here's why I say it let me
tell you I say because infinity makes
people uncomfortable yet you know the
biblical version of infinity is eternity
right all right there's me a new car
there's a word eternity no it's a it's a
fragrance there more science words they
get there yeah the event horizon yeah
once you get close yeah you you are any
people learn and grow that second
immortal like immortal thing is not a
cosmic word unity yes
no to me yes so and they want it big
because there's also infinite decimal
but nobody's in somebody's name on
anything that infinitesimally yeah yeah
nobody's name on that site so so the
infinite decimal so you
go out there and we don't know we say
infinity because we don't have any
reason to give any other value what I'm
going to say is 138 billion light years
across
we have no reason to we'll just say you
have to say if no reason to assign one
number versus another so we just say
infinite until till we have better
reason that to say infinite cuz you
can't go over there
you can't you do everything from Earth
you can't maybe one day you'll be such a
Luddite now you're trying to go to Mars
man we've been to Mars
oh yeah anytime yeah not a person our
robotic emissaries have yeah okay you
got your robot over there okay there is
a little GI Joe whatever over there
that's right you got a saying but you
can't we can stay over Joe that's a
smart thing that astronomers say and all
you guys say because I would say it to a
goal it's infinite man not what I say
everything only because I can't justify
giving any other value to it and we so
we just say this infinite until we have
a better saving your own ass by saying
that no cream you like yo it's infinite
then if you said listen it's 138 billion
then they can't wait to go you lied
oh no me no because I didn't say it is
infinite I said we have no reason to
think it isn't okay that's different
oh I like a little Elvis thing you just
did to me today that is a nice simple is
no infinite don't forget baby I'm doin
it well next question as are you I'll
give it over sin and God read it isn't
it right you kind of cosmic says what I
like it's kind of close well that's how
I feel
Haitian a little causeway I would home
it mama
I want another except I what everything
could be speaking Japanese I gave the
other store hey Neil deGrasse Tyson
there's only about a universe
I want to rule is it big or is it small
like you're still expanding like my
belly not my belly in physics we call
that the accretion disk recreation disk
I love that
are we ready yeah let's do it next
question I think this is this is guy
David Hamilton I think this is one of
the toughest things to wrap my head
around when we talk about space curving
or warping are we talking about
something permeating everything we see
that bends and warps yes so what is it
made of
and does that mean on some level space
isn't truly a vacuum
he's from mayagüez Puerto Rico alga
where's my Polly phone yes
testicle bond on seagull but the world's
largest radio telescope until two months
ago was in Puerto Rico what what part RC
bo odyssey boo that's a great evening
good evening but you're not gonna ask
who's got it now who's got the biggest
good who has it now where's it at China
what so if he's going to talk to us and
we need the most sensitive radio
telescope Chinese are gonna hear the
aliens first so the Chinese right here
4head that's right first of all it's
aliens here Chinese then I don't know
China Chinese is hard
Oh perfectly how an estate house oh it
looks a bit like whoa let's go back to
Puerto Rico
oh I'm just saying I'm trying to learn
Chinese it stopped it's hard if married
it's the hardest language ever even
though more people know that language
than any else you know what I'm saying
so how hard could it be yeah there's a
video yes of a guy speaking English
gibberish oh yeah and it is it is
mind-blowing so it is what English
sounds like to a non-native speaker I
love that
so how is it you know dates it's like I
should understand this but not really
nothing makes any sense at all there's
no accent you don't hear usually if
there's an accent ah it was but you
can't understand them it is it it is a
perfect American accent but nothing is
coming out nothing meaningful is coming
out at sea speaking trunk yes so it's up
to control that's a key speakers rap
with no real
run/walk did I answer the question yes
you did answer the question was the
question I got the question oh it was he
said that that it's about the space
curving Olin carbonate curve become
known I didn't answer the question
no so space so the idea that space is
curved is hard for us to see because
we're embedded in the space right so of
course it's hard to see in the same way
it's hard to know that earth is round
because we're kind of in a sense
embedded in the surface of that curve
and we are small relative to it if we
step out of the dimensionality and look
back yeah there's the round earth that's
what we did when we went to the moon
there's the rounder you step out of the
surface of the earth if we step out of
the dimensionality of our universe you
would see all the curvature manifested
by all the mass and the total curvature
represented in the universe itself so
it's all a matter of your your point of
view it's like a crappy relationship you
have to step out of it and say what the
hell was I doing with and sometimes unit
activation you don't even know Tilly's
when you're in distance right you think
it's normal until you don't just right
right exactly no right that we did that
was great do it okay we're moving on
right here we go this is Lucas Meza Nova
Instagram from Colombia or Libya oh yeah
whatever all the knuckle it said not
Colombia Oromia no I got it I know how
to pronounce Onoda he said it right
there trying to make sure he's like it's
grow colombiana Colombia some theories
say that our universe is a 3d hologram
of another universe with more dimensions
how would this affect space-time is
there a proof of this no there's no
proof but there's a very cogent argument
to support it and so the idea is that
the surface of an event horizon is the
complete record of anything that ever
have pet having passed through it so
that it is the sort of the ghost of all
things and so you can ask
have we passed through some other event
horizon the horizon of the universe can
be thought of as kind of like an event
horizon of the universe itself and so if
that's the case then we could be shadows
to a higher dimension on the edge of the
event horizon that they observe and so
it's been called a holographic printer
status yeah it's been suggested that
that we might as the Carrows yes so that
means this is very platonic Plato
imagined a world where you're in a cave
and there's a campfire and all you can
do is look in the adjacent wall and you
see shadows your own shadow and the
shadows of others so if you only see the
shadows and that is your reality then
look at how much you're missing when
someone else comes in and say wait a
minute there's a campfire there and
there people with clothing on and
there's always but all you see and know
is that wall that is your entire
existence so could it be that everything
we see and think is real is just a
projection of a much more textured
higher dimensional reality and in fact
we are we are blind deaf and dumb to it
all interesting yeah fantastic fantastic
yeah there's another one that was good
you answered it it's amazing
but Ricardo Montalban would be much
gonna be proud buyers everyone smile
only if you only if you have couldn't
see a letter yes okay down the Montalban
it's awesome you have you pull out the
Montalbano turning back to Boston in a
plan yeah the plane the cosmic hover
over there oh there you ready go this
guy is an interesting last name Jeff
sauce teresh star sauce Trek it might
because it's like I think it's polish
sauce Tareq I don't know he's from
Bethlehem Pennsylvania gotcha
is there anywhere in the universe where
you can find is really yes
no matter what follows in that question
the answer is probably yes okay is there
universes large it's old yo and stuff
happens in the universe where you can
find a zero state of energy perhaps
where even the cosmic background
radiation does not permeate man these
questions are some Malibu so that would
be ology that would be as absolute zero
we as far as we know the vacuum of space
is a seething ocean of what we call
virtual particles that are that are
predicted by quantum physics and quantum
physics has been right in every other
way it's ever made a prediction so we
have high confidence that what it's
saying is true but as long as you have
particles even in the vacuum there's
going to be an energy level there and
you never actually get to perfect zero
energy because of the quantum and so the
quantum prevents it we would need some
higher theory of understanding of the
universe that might enclose quantum
physics that will enable us to get to
places that our current understanding
does not but right now there's no way to
get to a perfect zero energy because
every state even the zero energy state
has a probability of having real energy
quantum physics requires it hmm yeah
yeah your quantum physics to quantum
physics oh it's at the end of the day
yet invisible math man is this will you
get this from Invisible Man this man
that can describe invisible things
that's what I met what the math itself
is not invisible guys like are you
getting it that is no I'm not accessible
man not accepting I you know like all
invisible now absolutely call you
because you don't understand it doesn't
mean it's not there I call it's
invisible to me because I don't want to
see it okay cuz you look the other way
great that's like because I decided to
say far is the foamer I thought yeah we
observe weird stuff happening in the lab
and for people who hate math this must
freak them out so we have scientists of
the day saying who lets attach math to
this to make it easy so we can bring
bring some understanding law so the
mathematics of quantum physics
six is an extraordinary achievement of
the human mind that's yeah yeah that's
another brain that you did something I
don't have that no but maybe you did and
you it still has to be found we think
that I could bring that out I can get
good the part of physics I think
mathematic and all always get better no
I think they're not we can become great
at anything we can always become better
at you're naturally good at math I don't
think I think it's a natural knack it is
there's people I knew in grade school
like some good some guys I knew and
girls that would just do they'd even
study they'd even study I had to use the
teachers example and flip the page over
to do look at the examples answer in the
back of my friends were just certain guy
they were just naturally good at it you
know that come naturally good at bad I I
spent a lot of time at home reading
books
what's your man yeah I mean I'm
naturally good cuz I mean I'm naturally
curious and I happen to apply that
curiosity to math and therefore got
higher grades and math then you did what
were you doing when you went home after
school I was confused so I just kept
watching cartoons man you know to me and
this stuff that you were reading you're
probably reading I was rereading reticle
stuff about mathematically in math I was
reading naturally have an inclination
for that because you would naturally get
it from that I had what is a reality in
childhood that I'd never left me that's
what I want I watch comedies man I so do
I love my mom comedy - you're funny guy
I continued my funniness in that way
comedian you funny guy but
astrophysicist because you're amazing at
math and invisible man because you see
the invisibility okay you made your case
are you ready now what's the next
question yeah Nicholas Lambert Facebook
why is dark matter presumed to exist
when modified Newtonian dynamics is able
to account for most of the missing mass
have businesses forgotten the principle
of Occam's razor Occam's razor comes up
sorrow comes razor when we come back to
Startalk we'll see in a moment
welcome back to Startalk I got Godfrey
here yo really comedian twit tweeting at
Godfrey comedian yes
excellent excellent Instagram and I'm
scum cut yeah you gotta come comedian
i'm comedian godfrey Instagram oh so
what someone else was Godfrey comedian
Instagram I I did that and I don't know
how to get into that I didn't I've
messed myself up okay I didn't know I
don't know how to get into that old
account so I had to go comedian God for
I'm stupid all right
median Godfrey Instagram yeah I get
Instagram but I'm not yet live on it I'm
gonna be I got a whole lot of stuff I
wanna put I'm sure you're not worried
about me I'm putting you on my Instagram
though all right
and go we got questions here someone
asked about yes dark matter and modified
Newtonian gravity as a solution at
Occam's razor Occam's razor there was I
I think was Earl of Occam okay British
fellow I think he was British who
uttered the following words multiplicity
ought not be posited without simplicity
okay which is what he means is I think I
got that quote right what he means is if
you have an explanation for something
it's long and complicated right and
someone else has a really simple
explanation
yeah the simplest explanation is
probably the correct one gotcha that's
all okay so for example let's take a
Pepsi before we understood epilepsy
there you are writhing on the ground and
so people had an argument for it well
the creator of the universe yeah in the
judeo-christian tradition has a nemesis
called the devil and that devil has
occupied the body of this particular
person because of the things this person
is done okay or the brain is misfiring
in its neural synapses okay so this this
is what we're contending with right
right so there you have it so in the
movie The Exorcist off like this is the
21st century I'd the 20th century I
think we got this one yeah all right so
the notion there is there's a modify
Newton's equations
of gravity then you don't need to posit
dark matter to explain things in the
universe and it would mean that our
understanding of gravity was flawed in
this way where when we corrected it we
wouldn't need to invoke this magical
mystical thing called dark matter and so
it turns out you can modify Newton's
laws of gravity to explain some of the
places where dark matter was otherwise
invoked there are other places where it
fails completely and we have no way
around that
we don't with the modifying you can't
modify Newton's gravity in the same way
to account for it and so that's why we
all haven't jumped on the bandwagon
adding terms to Newton's equations of
gravity that's why
awesome awesome let me keep going okay
like that one hope for it here we go
Adrian gray Marcin from California
California we currently can go we can
cleat levels are we curly can only go
forward in time with regards to black
hole trick nology given technologies for
acknowledging well given what little we
know about dark matter and dark energy
being our physics opposite do you think
our future insights and education on all
things dark will grant the option to
move backwards in time ooh
All Things duh yeah all right and black
hole technical technical is black hole
trick knowledge in technology okay so it
turns out if you you can warp the fabric
of space and time by the way I have been
told this I have not double-checked the
math these are people whose math in
other cases I trust implicitly so that
there's a configuration of curved
space-time where if you go around a
black hole in a particular trajectory
and come back around another one you can
actually go back in your own space-time
and so effectively go backwards in time
okay but it's still a little bit
mysterious to me
okay I got people who do this I'm not
the one who does it
right okay as a colleague of mine J
Richard got the third well actually I'm
co-author on in a book that was just
released I Princeton University Press
what's the title welcome to the universe
yeah yeah an Astrophysical tour just add
in local bookstore near you I'm gonna
get it so no so in there he talks about
these solutions to Einstein's equations
where you go back in time but they're
involved very exotic trajectories the
point is the bigger point of the
question is we've got dark matter we
don't know anything about it dark energy
we don't know anything about it and who
knows what else we don't know anything
about right that's kind of the fun part
of not known about something not even
knowing that you don't know about
something right okay
so with all of this could it be that
once all of that to figure it out we can
have access to the past I can't rule
that out I will not rule that out almost
everything we've discovered that came
about from profound ignorance has
transformed civilization think about the
discovery of electricity whoo what it
has done yes it's the probably the
greatest thing to ever happen to
civilization I can't even imagine cannot
have matches it I can't even imagine not
plugging stuff plugging stuff in
flicking a switch it is a switch right
don't know how it works don't care it's
there it's not even and we've made it
into something that's not even only
about light movies and movies just and
ever every everything ok so this is
harnessing something that previously we
ran away from or didn't understand so so
I look forward to a future where dark
matter and dark energy come to be
understood but then that only puts us in
a new place to stand
possibly observing new unknowns that
today are yet to be dreamt of all right
I like that maybe access to our past
network lurks among those on the day I
like that next ride there we go I like
this so I think gonzo know Gonzalo
Martin face book from Chile land of the
stars Derby
gonzalo Martine yes Martine how you know
you know him I say Marty he said Martin
Martin this did Marty you're in South
America Arden I didn't want to be
American thanks Martin monotheism sorry
this is land of the stars he said land
of the start my yacht all the data that
went into my PhD thesis was obtained in
the Andes Mountains of Chile
Wow deep settle to low low
inter-american Observatory Oh outside of
the town of La Sirena fantastic if you
think that yeah I'm not either try
status it was my I say specific office
fun times to go and that's you notice
you doesn't matter yes I can't do that I
can't even think you do the whole
universe thing smooth like do you do
your tile your book got welcome to the
universe so you don't say like might
look no no no yeah none okay the dusty
if sound won't travel through space how
does the sound of celestial bodies whoa
whoa wait it sound won't travel through
space how does the sound of celestial
bodies can be listened to
yeah whoo I guess they Jesus said no um
that's because we are not consistent
with our vocabulary we are we play
loosey-goosey with our words okay so
when we say let's listen for aliens who
are send us radio waves
it means we're pulling out a radio
telescope trying to detect
electromagnetic waves light sent by them
from another place in the galaxy that
has now trapped and this signal has
traveled through the vacuum of space we
can then turn that electromagnetic
signal into sound if you want but that
doesn't mean they're making sounds
they're making electromagnetic energy
and so you know we have the unfortunate
word radio because radio became not only
the name for the light ways it became
the name of the object that brought you
radio waves
turned into sounds so we hear we hear
the word radio and we think sound the
astrophysicist hears the word radio
waves and we think radio wave light so
so we've been sloppy I feel I feel bad
sloppy no sound moves through space in
the vacuum of space period okay period
so even if we say that we're listening
sound with sound wave sound can't travel
through sound needs a medium to vibrate
right to transmit itself from one place
to another that's right
so so like for example let's say a
comedy club you need a a particular
building for sound to travel right is
that how microphones work I don't know
what you're talking about I thought I
had it what sound needs a medium to
travel through air is a medium it
strikes through the air
your vibrates okay so what did you just
say I just got confused
I said air propagates sound right okay
but light does not need a medium to
propagate through one of the great
discoveries of the 20th century this is
not necessary it can travel through the
vacuum of space which is why this the
sign on every broadcast door that says
on the air on air right there on space
okay the radio waves don't need air ah
the neat it is technically on the air
but air is not carrying it if you're in
the moon it could still you could still
broadcast your TV and radio and and
there's no air you have to say on the
vacuum of space watching okay I guess I
was confused no that's just a weird
thing but yeah a weird thing okay but in
comedy club you sneak it goes to the
microphone
it comes it gets converted into
electrical signals comes out two
speakers right people hear you directly
through the air other people hear you
through the speakers through the air
okay yeah
there it is oh we got to lightning round
oh if we built the time machine what's
the best way to long time isn't it the
same as Earth years ooh if you have
access to your time line there is no
logging of time because time is a
permanent fixture in your life okay damn
it
how would you explain same way when
you're looking at a map yeah you're not
logging distance because the whole map
is just right there boom you just see
New York to California
it's just all there right not logging
distance from New York to California
while you're looking at a map any more
than you would need to log time looking
at your entire timeline of your life
oh it theater Smith how would you
explain space-time to a non-scientist or
anatomist who is generally bad but
fascinated by physics I would say sir
that if there's a sir yes wasn't
what's-his-name
Oh Theater Smith you have never been at
a place unless it was at a time and
you've never been at a time unless you
are at a place recognizing that fact you
will understand that space and time are
forever intertwined with one another
you've never said I'll meet you 10
o'clock tomorrow where I'll meet you the
corner of Hollywood and Vine when we
know intuitively that space and time are
conjoined even if you don't think
actively about it space and time were
always together like beans and rice
oh it just took Einstein to show us hey
it's a fundamental property of the
cosmos Wow let's do it
okay we're in the known universe this is
I'm sorry
ah this is uh this is a Kyle Sakia sake
oh we're in the known universe would you
experience extreme time dilation near
the surface of a black hole you time
will go so slowly for you that the
entire future history of the universe
unfolds before your eyes that is perhaps
the most serious time dilation that
exists so avoid black holes in fact I'm
going outside one more kiss Chris
couples oh here we go
Lord couple dat Lord couple's Twitter
could gravitational bleeding from other
dimensions be what we call dark matter
that is my favorite explanation for what
dark matter could be but I'm told I've
had this conversation with folks it's
unlikely only because it would have to
bleed in a higher dimension out of the
other universe and if you bleed in a
higher dimension it drops off much
faster than one over R squared gravity
gravity drops off as one over R squared
it would drop off as one over R cubed so
that means to feel it in another
universe
had to be really really really really
strong in the adjacent universe for
while it's dropping off as one over the
distance cube for you to feel it in the
adjacent universe if that were the case
then Dark Matter would just be ordinary
matter harassing matter in our universe
the ordinary matter in a parallel
universe harassing us rationals I'd have
no other way to account for that -
collecting but it's notice harassing
with harassing okay it's either it's
bothering yes I got my planet I got my
star I got my gravity in a day now
there's more gravity I got a mess with
I'm aware it's coming from what it's
about why you messing with me I guess
with why you mess with me question of
faith if I'm harassing me matter find
you if I give ya copy we gotta call this
we got it we got to land this plane you
awesome jockeys thanks for being on
Startalk
thank you I'm back again glad you
slipped us in your schedule you're on
your way to California
why don't I light a couch got some gigs
there you'll talk about in another time
another time right but add another space
time that's too cool
fantastic there you go I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson this has been Startalk and as
always I bid you to keep looking up this
is Startalk
[Music]
you
[Music]